[Music] I'll re-
input The
choices that will cause a chemical reaction between the three of us Nagi and Barrow
Update the scenery you see from now
on
If things continue as they are now, there won't be a chemical reaction with Barrow Then Nagee's passing course
[Applause]
Infinite images of goals will spring to mind Nagi's
moving,
so that I can
compete with my passes Win off-the-ball from him
I'm going to evolve to a level where I can take it here, right? A fast
bus Are you trying to compete with me?
I
made a shooting course with the trap of this
play that's even higher than my image
This
is the chemical reaction between me and him